[Applauso]
internet è la collina non è non sono i
cellulari non è il cellulare e se
vogliamo parlare di quello che potrà
essere la comunicazione e l'informazione
nel 2039 quindi a vent'anni da oggi
dobbiamo avere ben presente questa
differenza questo aspetto e provare a
interpretare internet come libertà
questa equazione internet come libertà e
proviamo a farlo partendo da tre di
queste libertà le conosciamo bene lo so
quindi non stiamo dicendo nulla di nuovo
in questa fase però vogliamo provare a
ripassarle insieme la prima libertà è la
libertà di comunicazione la libertà di
comunicare con chiunque nel mondo
potendo scegliere e potenzialmente
raggiungere qualsiasi fonte la seconda è
la libertà di lavorare ovunque liberi da
costrizioni spazio temporali una bella
libertà la terza è la libertà di
esprimere le nostre opinioni e anche di
scriverle in qualsiasi luogo della rete
e non solo
guardando a queste tre libertà
sembrerebbe un bel mondo utopico per
citare qualcuno appena sceso da questo
palco
eppure c'è qualcosa che ci è sfuggita di
mano
proviamo ad analizzarne uno alla volta
partiamo dalla libertà di comunicare e
chiaro che avendo questo accesso
infinito a tutte le fonti di
informazioni penseremmo di essere
assolutamente più informati e
probabilmente anche più liberi ma se
consideriamo un aspetto che è quello di
banalmente di considerare che l'unesco
calcola che oltre 2 milioni di libri
sono oggi pubblicati ogni anno è
soltanto su amazon
ce n'è uno nuovo ogni 5 minuti miliardi
di parole miliardi di contenuti miliardi
di video miliardi di contenuti di
qualsiasi genere ci raggiungono in ogni
istante e competono per la nostra
attenzione allora cosa cosa succede alle
nostre vite
tendenzialmente la sensazione maggiore è
quella di avere una sorta di ansia da
perdita di controllo si ha accesso all
universo intero delle informazioni ma
molto spesso non sappiamo esattamente
dove indirizzare la nostra attenzione e
questo non ci regala mediamente vite più
informate molto spesso in questo
disorientamento cosa facciamo
rinunciamo piuttosto preferiamo essere
raggiunti da qualsiasi informazione
piuttosto che scegliere quelle che
vogliamo realmente approfondire e questo
in generale cosa rende rende le nostre
vite
certamente non più felici certamente non
più serene perché tendenzialmente
abbiamo costantemente la paura di
perderci qualcosa e questa paura ci fa
stare connessi connessi tantissimo forse
troppo non vogliamo dare valutazioni
comunque stare molto connessi con la
sensazione costante di poterci perdere
qualcosa
ecco che questa situazione è sicuramente
fonte di stress e questo stress non ci
regala vite più informate non ci regala
vite più libere veniamo alla seconda
libertà la libertà di lavorare ovunque
ve l'abbiamo detto internet per me è la
collina la libertà di lavorare ovunque
tendenzialmente è un qualcosa di
positivo
ma a rovescio della medaglia esiste un
rovescio della medaglia
perché se lavorare ovunque vuol dire
essere costantemente connessi
se lavorare ovunque significa essere
sempre reperibili allora anche qui
abbiamo un deficit
come dire di libertà chi viene in aiuto
questo ragazzo oserei dire perché molto
giovane e francesco marconi che è il
responsabile ricerca e sviluppo del
vostro journal e anche massimo esperto
mondiale di intelligenza artificiale
applicata al giornalismo che cosa ci
dice marconi in questo libro diventa
autore della tua vita ci invita a
prendere possesso della nostra vita di
scrivere il copione della nostra vita di
cercare qual è la missione che ci potrà
fare stare meglio e costruisce in questo
senso una sorta di algoritmo della
felicità è un algoritmo importante
perché scritto da un uomo di algoritmi
ma un algoritmo che è totalmente giocato
sulla nostra natura umana un algoritmo
che ci consente di concentrarci su
quello che la nostra missione e in
questo modo orientare la nostra ricerca
delle informazioni
eppure per me questa concretizzazione
questa missione non sempre ha portato la
vita a essere più serena come come vi
stavo dicendo perché molto spesso sulla
collina
noi siamo costantemente operati e
uccisi quasi dalla quantità di flussi
digitali che costantemente dettano le
nostre vite quindi in questo senso
questa libertà non sempre secondo me la
stiamo scegliendo nella direzione giusta
e veniamo a un'altra libertà la terza
quella di esprimere liberamente le
nostre opinioni
ovunque nel mondo è una importante
libertà perché la democrazia delle idee
un nome molto importante per e anche qui
ricorriamo a un libro un libro
importante 21 elezioni per il
ventunesimo secolo di un personaggio
fantastico lo conoscerete sicuramente si
chiama you all harari che ci dice che in
questo clima politico la qualunque
pensiero critico del liberismo e della
democrazia
oggi può essere come dire manipolato da
movimenti i liberali e questo ci deve
far pensare ci deve fare riprendere
possesso della nostra direzione della
direzione a che vogliamo dare alla
informazione e lo so l'avete già fatto
questo esperimento mentale oggi vi
invito però a pensare nuovamente a
essere di fronte come gene e paltrow
un'altra volta nella vostra giornata di
oggi di fronte a due possibilità
una è quella del dell'oggi del digitale
e della informazione e della
comunicazione come l'abbiamo descritta
fino qui
l'altra è un'altra porta è una porta che
noi tutti possiamo prendere a che fare
totalmente con una nuova narrazione del
mondo e la nuova narrazione del mondo
parte dalla consapevolezza della delle
nostre narrazioni della possibilità di
raccontare l'informazione e la
comunicazione di vivere immersi in
questo universo di informazioni e di
comunicazioni in un modo nuovo e allora
proviamo a riconsiderare le stesse
libertà di prima e facendolo proviamo a
orientare anche io non ho la certezza di
che cosa succederà nel futuro ma ho una
certezza è la certezza è quella che ha
ognuno di noi è data la possibilità di
costruire queste tre libertà nel nostro
futuro
perché se è vero che diciamo gli
strumenti di diffusione di informazioni
sono ormai a disposizione di tutti sono
anche a disposizioni per immettere
nell'ecosistema informativo come dire
elementi più di valoriali e di valore e
analizziamo le vediamo la libertà di
comunicazione noi pensiamo a questa
connessione globale e la pensiamo sempre
legata al tema del digitale invece la
connessione globale una connessione
umana internet connette è vero ma gli
uomini sono connessi tra loro in reti di
connessione fisica e per far risuonare
il fisico e il digitale
servono delle chiavi armoniche
la chiave armonica principale è quella
della ricerca della verità è questa
ricerca costante della verità questo
riportare la verità
al centro del lavoro giornalistico e non
ci dobbiamo vergognare di questa parola
dobbiamo sceglierla abbracciarla e
considerarla come fondamentale per la
nostra narrazione in questo modo abbiamo
anche la possibilità di fare una
migliore comunicazione vi accompagno
ancora con un libro un libro
fondamentale un libro di dieci anni fa
invertising è un libro che inverte la
rotta della pubblicità in questo caso ma
della comunicazione in generale dando a
noi tutti la possibilità di una nuova
narrazione una nuova narrazione che non
è soltanto una narrazione delle aziende
ma è sempre più anche una nostra
narrazione una nostra responsabilità
quella di porci davanti all'ecosistema
dell'informazione della comunicazione e
renderci conto di essere noi attori
principali di questa trasformazione di
poterci chiedere nel momento in cui
decideremo di postare qualcosa aggiunge
realmente valore all'ecosistema
complessivo e poi la libertà di lavorare
ovunque insomma ormai l'avete capito per
me era fondamentale un sogno di libertà
quello di poter lavorare e fare il mio
lavoro ovunque nel mondo
ma oggi è immaginandoci nel 2039
l'abbiamo già visto molti lavori e non
solo quelli industriali e produttivi
saranno sostituiti da software di
intelligenza artificiale
allora come facciamo cosa facciamo di
questo tempo liberato dal lavoro e bene
abbiamo un'enorme opportunità quella di
riportare la creatività al centro quella
di fare in modo che le nostre persone
abbiano più tempo per loro stesse per
riuscire a diventare più creativa in
grado di porre le giuste domande ai
software di intelligenza artificiale per
indirizzarli verso la soluzione dei
grandi problemi dell'umanità e questo è
una grande libertà una grande
opportunità che data alla nostra libertà
e infine abbiamo l'ultima delle libertà
questa è molto importante perché a che
fare con come dire focus 2039 possiamo
immaginare un giornalismo diverso
possiamo immaginare di scegliere i
nostri condottieri di senso di riuscire
a rischi restituire importanza a quei
mediatori che nel con internet hanno
perso un ruolo centrale dare loro
fiducia
in cambio del loro lavoro di costruttori
di senso e di smascherato ridiciamo
della falsità e allora in questo caso
dobbiamo anche avere il coraggio di
finanziare il giornalismo di qualità
perché il giornalismo di qualità e
attivismo e la possibilità all'interno
delle conversazioni sui social di
interagire e di non pensare più di avere
un pulpito da cui parlare
ma essere costantemente in una relazione
di ascolto e reazione e come dice
arianna ciccone che la fondatrice del
festival internazionale del giornalismo
in questo bellissimo post su valigia blu
e l'opportunità di dare un nuovo modo di
partecipare chiedere di correggere gli
errori e di ringraziare chi corregge i
nostri errori nell'ecosistema
dell'informazione e in questo modo
ridare quella forza di libertà di
democraticità all'internet e in quindi a
noi stessi e alla cui sistema delle
informazioni e della comunicazione e
quindi eccoci qua siamo di fronte alle
nostre due porte possiamo scegliere la
prima quella dell'accelerazione continua
quella che abbiamo già in qualche modo
intrapreso che quella che non fa
risuonare in armonia al mondo digitale
con quello analogico quella che possiamo
dire l'internet del cellulare oppure
possiamo scegliere la seconda porta
quella di un internet della collina se
vogliamo giocare con questo discorso un
internet che ci porta a riprendere
possesso e responsabilità perché l'eco
sistema dell'informazione e della
comunicazione non è altro che il nostro
il futuro dell'ecosistema
dell'informazione non è altro che il
nostro futuro è oggi abbiamo la
possibilità di partecipare
e ricordiamo le parole di una bellissima
canzone così chiudiamo con un momento
veramente toccante quella di gaber che
dice libertà non è uno spazio libero
libertà è partecipazione e quindi sta a
noi decidere oggi quale porte
intraprendere se vogliamo veramente che
il nostro futuro risuoni con l'eco
sistema dell'informazione e della
comunicazione
sta a noi scegliere quale porta a
scegliere e intraprendere grazie
[Applauso]